i love to have a clear schedule of the  week  exactly what i'm going to do what is  everything going to do to support me  emotionally physically spiritually  financially relationally what am i going  to schedule in and i also schedule in  leisure time okay i'm gonna schedule  these four hours where i'm gonna do  nothing or i'll do whatever i want or  i'll just hang out with friends i  schedule it in that way i'm just not  distracted by my phone  or whatever is happening in the world  i really try to eliminate  the negative distractions from my life  the best that i can and in no way am i  perfect but it's something i try to  focus on by having a clear schedule so  when i know where i need to be  and i know where i need to show up and  how i'm supposed to show up  it it allows me to stay focused